all right we are live on youtube
dr brian keating dr eric weinstein
how are you my friend i miss you very
much and i you sir good to be with you
is it cinco de mayo
yes felice cinco de mayo it always comes
on the 5th of may every freaking year
it's like clockwork
i've decided to celebrate and be festive
you've got uh five glasses of tequila
like me no i've got the mexican hat
potential oh on the bottom of my mug
well played sir
buenos dias to you my friend well we're
gonna get in uh right off the bat we're
gonna talk about the most exciting
subjects
in your universe my audience has missed
you as much as i have
and
we want to make sure that we uh we kind
of
give give the people what they're
interested in and that today involves a
whole host of of issues we're going to
talk about aliens and a possible new
solution to the fermi paradox we're
going to talk about uh your new and ever
evolving and a good way
uh theories and feelings about
cryptocurrencies inflation
and so forth and then we're going to
talk about uh
some less controversial subjects like
abortion
supreme court leaks um
and uh wherever the day takes us so
how exciting yes and i was pleased uh
pleased to see uh recently a man by the
name of musk uh has has kind of taken a
new stance for which he's taking extreme
attacks and hostility and i wondered
eric you know if he might have a little
bit of buyer's remorse right now do you
feel like this prize you know everyone's
always the richest man in the world
that's true he has five times this
amount that's true but you know if i if
i you know
took away your your family car uh you
would feel it uh you know i would feel
it and so i feel like this is a
tremendous amount of money and i want to
take you back to uh we started pandemic
podcasting together two years ago
exactly so uh you know congratulations
on our anniversary but um in the in
between there was this thing called
clubhouse i don't know if you remember
this thing called clubhouse and that was
the hottest ticket in the world
everybody wanted it and get on it
i haven't used it in months i don't know
about you uh like i said i don't know
you might be on there but i'm not on
there um do you think he might be having
buyer's remorse he think he might look
back and say this was the clubhouse of
2022 eventually and i should have given
up a quarter of my net worth
um if there is buyer's remorse
my guess is that it hasn't set in yet
because
i believe that there's so there's a lot
of low-hanging fruit to improve twitter
and
you know elon i don't know elon at all
i know tons of people who know him um my
impression of him from afar
is very confused he does seem to be in
many ways the world's most
forward-thinking person
um
at least at the level of you know
forward thinking what can we what can we
actually do
um so i'm pretty impressed with him
intellectually as a public intellectual
then you know then there are layers then
there's the idea that he has to be
chaotic so he is very trump-like in many
ways in terms of how he uses twitter
and how he attempts not to be
constrained because you know
there are going to be sec rules and lots
of lawyers and pr people telling you
can't say this you can't do that and
he's decided that he wants to be free
and so there's this paradox sort of a
laffer curve when you have no money and
when you have lots of money
you tend to be in a weird way less free
than people with intermediate levels and
so in a strange way i sort of see him as
a very rich person
choosing to put a lot of his
wealth
at risk so that he can be free
and that too is very forward thinking
now what i know about twitter
is that
current twitter has all sorts of
obviously soluble problems in terms of
you can just fire a bunch of people and
you can make rules about
algorithmic um transparency and the like
and then when you get to the end of
plucking all the low-hanging fruit then
you've got the problem of the underlying
technology allows any person
to post something instantly
and you know what we've seen is we've
seen first-person shooters
uh looking like they come out of a video
game uh in the christ church
mosque massacre uh that was i think
streamed live on facebook so
the problem is us it's not twitter it's
not the technology it's the the
technology
hooked up
lots of people many of whom have mental
health issues many of whom
are incredibly chaotic
um
[Music]
talking to each other without common
background without
an ability to you know to know who's
gonna post what when
so
in that world i don't think there's a
solution
so
you know the great danger is is that
he's bought something and he's got the
first 17 fixes lined up
and
i don't think the problem is going to
occur then i think the problem is going
to occur once you've fixed all of those
things what are you left with
and you know one of the things he's
signaled brian is that he believes that
removing anonymity
will be a large portion of the solution
and
i do think it will
do a lot to solve the problems
but there is a hardcore of people who
are happy to be
known
who are incredibly abusive
and think it's funny and then there's a
very large market for abuse and i think
people haven't really realized that that
abuse tends to be one of the most
important products that the internet
knows how to distribute
and because
you can't sign up for abuse you can't
say hey i want to see who's abusing who
today am i feeling like i should abuse
somebody else i'm not feeling so good
about myself
when you do that
you realize you can't be honest that
you're really up for going to the
coliseum to see people get hurt you're
really starting to say oh no
i'm here for the comedy it's just comedy
it's just fun just laughs or um
i think this makes the world a better
place i'm calling people out
who are ghoulish and horrible
well no you're really just up for abuse
and you don't have many ideas and your
life is empty and and that's what you're
doing okay
that
problem of all sorts of people selling
this one product that has an enormous
audience for it
is going to plague twitter so i think
that there is buyer's remorse
but i think elon can go make more money
what he's trying to do is he's trying to
say we have to have some property that
isn't in control
under the con how do i say this
you have to have some major property
that isn't under the control of whatever
this wrong woke thing is
and
you know you have
fox and you have um
i don't know newsmax
these are not me
these are not major
or you know
even the blaze or or
or the daily wire or daily caller any
any of these things i think
they're not like msnbc new york times
npr
and the fact that all of these sort of
form formally formerly
respectable properties gone completely
insane
uh
haven't broken rank
buying one
and saying hey we're not going to change
the
the logo and we're not going to change
the mast uh the masthead
completely but what we are going to do
is we are going to stop making it
possible to be ridiculous in this
coordinated assault on reality now
that's why everybody on the
it's not the left brian it's like the
it's some sort of a partnership between
the establishment left
and their revolutionary army
that they deploy to try to undo
everything that gets in the in the path
of what i would call the rent-seeking
elite who are in control of the
democratic party
um
that that thing
he's taking that on and i think you have
to look at it he's not taking it on
necessarily from being a conservative
he's taking it on from saying i can't
live under these people one second
longer
yeah and you know i think looking back
at you know the history of these
platforms i mean we see
facebook kind of falling out of favor
and we saw the
massive contributions in the previous
election election by zuckerberg which
didn't curry him any favor with the the
people that uh obviously he was
advocating for so i wonder you know in
this and i wonder if you saw any of the
interviews that zuckerberg's been on
this you know kind of world tour lately
uh on lex's show and on um another
podcast uh tim ferriss uh and and no
one's really asking him you know these
they're really tough questions uh so i
wonder you know is it is it really true
that we we look to these um we look to
these people as if they're uh so lucky
to have the resources to buy this it
seems to me like a nightmare hellscape
to wake up in the morning and have a new
york times hit piece like elon faces
today with his uh south african
childhood brought into play as if he had
choices to where he was born
geez
i just
why don't you just call everything white
supremacist
you know just just just get it over with
everybody's a nazi everybody's always
why
they just waste our time because the new
york times used to be an important
newspaper and and still capable of doing
things
um we all have to have a discussion
framed by them
and my feeling is
okay let's just take some random person
you know
let's take uh um just give me a generic
republican
marco rubio
okay marco rubio is there any truth to
the fact that he was connected to the
cuban cuban
mafia okay now we're gonna discuss marco
rubio being connected to the cuban mafia
for no reason other than the fact that
somebody was able to put that question
in a sentence
uh at the top of an article so my
feeling is we could also um
why does marco rubio seemingly target
america's children oh is he targeting
america's children like we just changed
from the cuban mafia to some different
story
um
i think we've got to just stop start
with the idea of shut up
like
you don't if you don't have much
hush
that's where i feel like you know this
this takeover of twitter he took over
something which is built by people that
had an ideological
bent against him and have a very clear
perspective on what they want to promote
and what they don't want to promote and
and highlight versus not and uh i feel
like again i feel like it's like a booby
prize i do feel like at some point even
i or you you know would wake up and just
say
you know like there's so much richness
in the world like who cares to have
these battles with people that only get
points the more polarized that they
speak the more they try to punch up and
take down eric weinstein i get i get
like those dungeons remember that
dungeons and dragons you know hit points
if i take eric's car you know i get your
hit points well you've got 690 000
people that follow oh i've only got who
gives a freaking crap you know i mean
all these people do remarkably well and
uh with without it and and i feel like
he's catering to this tribe of maybe a
hundred thousand semi-woke you know if
you want to call it that uh journalists
people in the beltway and the corridor
in the northeast and then the west coast
and why do you want to spend so much of
your i mean again it's like fifth right
brian frank i don't know what you're
asking about the key issue is we've got
to buy one of these things there has to
be a university that's actually a
university a news service that's
actually a news service a place a public
square that's a public square
like we've lost everything essentially
and then there's these false equivalents
oh no no fox it's like look
fox i still treat as
right-wing propaganda
the the major issue is is that
left-leaning properties went insane
as opposed to merely biased
and
you know like there's one of these
things with um
hey
remember we told you that ivormectin was
horse dewormer that you shouldn't take
it well it turns out that if we lose roe
v wade
a horse
ulcer medication can be used to induce
uh
off-label of spontaneous abortions in
humans that's good so just go to your
vet you're covered and i'm thinking
okay i really appreciate that what
you're really doing is telling me that
you have the right to contradict
yourselves and the rest of us are all
hypocrites
for simply trying to get through a day
but you have an absolute right to say
whatever you want whenever you want that
it's a game
and i have to admit i i have caught
people chuckling like hey did you see
what i just put out today that'll bend
their minds because it contradicts what
i said three weeks ago
you're just thinking okay i get it
everybody's joyriding right
yeah right you get those uh get those
adrenaline bumps and and then speaking
of that you know this this thing i don't
know if the deal is actually done or
what it is but you know obviously a lot
of it was leaked ahead of time and and
so forth and and you have this like it's
like the fifth estate now so so you have
the fourth estate which is media and
then there's like this this leakage
class you know
the people beyond the uh beyond the
curtain that will leak the story that
eventually does get pipelined directly
into the mainstream veins of of the
fourth estate of journalism and what do
you make of this i mean this people are
celebrating as heroes this leak uh you
know to the to the from the supreme
court decision which as i understand it
could put people's lives in danger right
i don't want to be too specific but this
this this thing is not set a law yet and
remark regardless of how you feel about
it um and i can hear opinions on both
sides uh before i actually before i get
to that eric
about two years ago on the portal you
did this wonderful kind of verbal essay
and everybody's asking when the portal
is going to come back i hope it'll be
soon no no questions asked about that
today but
you did it you did a wonderful uh verbal
essay and once you talked about the
trouble with ambiguity and you talked
about superpositions and how
inharmonious they are for the human mind
and the human mind hates uh ambiguity
and loves resolution even if the
resolution's wrong
and you talk about abortion you talked
about gun control i wonder could you
recapitulate that discussion it was in
the context of you know kind of a
shredding your state uh of a baby being
real versus not have you changed your
opinions and can you first recap
can you recount that that that wonderful
kind of analogy that you used
yeah of course i i should listen to the
portal and find out what i what i said
or thought um
you know you're just bring your own
words on here you remember that charles
barkley said he was he was taken out of
context in his own autobiography so
we're not company
well you know the the
famous
um
description of one of my favorite
classical music pieces samsung's second
piano concerto is that it begins with
bach and it ends with offenbach and
conception
you know it begins uh
when you're talking about terminating a
pregnancy it sort of begins with
spermicide and enzyme infanticide
and anything that has that property of
being on a continuum that connects
something incredibly trivial to
something unthinkable
but naturally you know through the
intermediate value theorem
there's got to be some point where that
thing becomes
a meaningful life
and
the political expediency has said
we're going to turn this into an
intellectual football right and so yeah
one side is going to pretend that
something is a baby the instant the
sperm
nudges close to the egg
and
somebody else is going to pretend that
it's just the mother's body
four seconds before delivery
okay well there's a black hole that i
don't want to get into because
what they're really saying is we know
that we've got to make this wrong
statement
in order to get where we need to go and
if you won't make the wrong statement
with with us you're hitler
it's like okay so add hitler to white
supremacist it's just look brian this is
all so dumb it's so innovating i mean
the real issue is we should go back to
reading griswold uh you know before roe
where we get the penumbra argument uh i
think it's advanced by william o douglas
in the warren court and we should ask
ourselves how sophisticated is that
decision and then you know the issue
with roe
uh of course is that for its time there
was no plan b
uh back in that day
the world was a very different place
um you know there are arguments in all
different directions i don't want to get
into any of that because the issue
you know suffice it to say i
behave
pretty much as a pro-choice person early
on in the pregnancy and i've
you know protested in the streets
in order to
make sure that women have
safe legal access
to
disposing of their pregnancies early on
and i'm pretty pro
babies rights right before
you know somebody's about to give birth
and that that can't go to anybody's
party
yeah i mean i remember my dad of a
blessed memory he used to joke you know
on my 33rd birthday he said i believe in
abortion up until the 99th trimester and
uh yeah
but now it's not a joke i mean you have
people that that are effectively saying
you know such things as uh you know a
pregnant person of course we have to be
respectful it's amazing how we went from
we can't define what a woman is and with
regard to the supreme court right media
stuff
i
i value your time and my time
and we can get into like
trans what are they thinking or
do you know what someone's always been
accused of next and my feeling is this
is my only time on this planet and i
have you know an esteemed physicist
colleague a worldly guy
i don't want to talk about
any of the ridiculously stupid stuff
that everybody wants us to talk about
so all right well thanks for joining the
into the impossible podcast it's been a
pleasure and uh please visit comment and
subscribe
women get pregnant and give birth and we
should call some number of biological
men women uh i think uh
because
that there is a programming issue but
this has gotten out of hand and i'm not
going to sort it out with you on this
particular program and we haven't lost
our mind and i'm not going to throw
biology out the window because
you know
renee richards is you know is upset
we have to be compassionate
and deal with everybody in our society
we should be kind and we can't lose our
minds at the same time and we failed
and we failed to have these discussions
we failed to talk about the real the
reality of pregnancy we won't sit down
with carnegie stages and embryonic
development and say when does the neural
tube
and the neural crest form and what is
the richness of neural activity and all
these kind of things that matter to me
instead we're going to
try to talk to each other pro-life no
pro-choice no pro-life
let's let somebody else do it
all right well let's pivot to another
existential crisis well no no oh okay
i'm gonna get to the leak all right yes
i want to talk about the league okay
let's go back to that yep
um
i think it's important i just had a
conversation with somebody i've known a
very long time as a lawyer last night
and the lawyer said you know it's wrong
to leak and i probably would have
considered it
i said why
oh because i think it's so important
that women have access to reproductive
rights that even the unthinkable should
be done
okay
um
i
appreciated the candor
i think that's insane
i mean i think that what's really
becoming very clear is that very few of
us trust democracy
trust the court
trust our scientists the level of
loss of trust
has led to a large number of us
unwilling to carry the culture
of the united states that animates the
constitution and its other governing
documents
i think this is something i don't know
how to communicate
if you don't carry the culture of the
united states which is that you're
willing to believe in a fiction that
nine druids can discern the the meaning
of the constitution and legal conflict
which is
i'm going to say it right here it's a
fiction
but i agree to that fiction
i agree to the fiction
that a majority of the electoral college
or one day maybe the electorate has
the wisdom the best wisdom available to
choose the president blah blah blah
i think many of us have decided that
they don't feel we don't feel like
carrying the culture
and without the culture it's a piece of
parchment with ink
there's nothing more if you can't
animate the document if you if you're
unwilling
to pretend to believe in the things that
are necessary to keep the experiment
running because it's like no with
merrick garland they that's out the
window no with pork you know that's
ridiculous no no you don't understand
the the activism on the warren court
destroyed the okay look
i'm i know all of the right-wing
complaints about the left and the
judiciary and i know all the complaints
uh in reverse and there's two separate
stories and i'm like i feel like i'm the
middle child it's like you idiots are
going to lose us everything oh you want
to pack the court oh you want to do this
you wouldn't okay the filibuster right
we're not going to survive this you
morons and you know my feeling about
this is i
my desire to watch joe biden donald
trump
all of these
these people are not going to be around
for that long my kids have a lot of run
time left i just worry that what we
haven't realized
is that a giant chunk of both parties
have gone revolutionary they don't
believe in the country
how does it bode for the
remainder of the union of these states
then
um
i think we don't realize what we're
doing you know
i have this memory of being on a school
bus when i was a little kid
and
figuring out that if i could get the
kids to sway back and forth in unison
we could actually have a large effect in
aggregate
and we started swaying the bus and the
bus was really like
rocking at some incredible level just
from all of these kids going back and
forth and once they figured out that
this was real they got more and more
enthusiastic
and it felt like we were pretty
close to being in danger of actually
getting the bus to do something it
wasn't supposed to do now
i feel like that's what we're doing is
that we have this idea that the bus
represents like adulthood there's
nothing you can do to take down the
united states of america it's some super
stable superpower you can mouth off it's
not true
we are now in danger of disassembling
this beautiful experiment because we're
bored
and we're like mischievous and we want
to have fun so maybe we'll riot the
streets this summer summer is coming up
always a good idea to have mostly
peaceful
gatherings and we can
uh call each other names and bring some
guns and then we can discuss who shot
whom
um
i think
you ever you've got like more kids than
i can remember you probably have the
same number as the last time we spoke
but i'm not even positive of that yeah
no no no abortions or anything
you know this line
in maurice sendik's where the wild
things are
he says let the wild rumpus start start
yeah
i think that's that this causes the wild
rumpus
yeah exactly which you know i think
brings a you know
oh yeah since we talked last in late uh
december uh we did record about a month
ago we may release that at some point
but uh we've had this um obviously this
existential crisis looming
in the uh in eastern europe
and i wonder you know
if we can uh kind of think about that
that rumpus governed by the same clan of
people you just talked about with the
addition of somebody who brings the
average age of the
discussants down slightly to you know
closer to 70 of vladimir putin
now things are getting serious and i
remember not too long ago you advocated
for something and i was like he can't be
serious
my god he can't be serious and that was
for
a demonstration event of the awesomeness
of the release of of the binding energy
between nucleons and
and that was a call to
you know a demonstration of the of the
of the fearful power of the wildest
rumpus of all which is nuclear
thermonuclear
weapons
and you advocated for a non-radioactive
but but still thermonuclear um
detonation so to speak of
of the kind that we could witness
obviously not on catastrophic scale but
i wonder what was
at first i was shocked i thought eric's
being a provocateur
what's the thinking behind that what
would that do for humanity to see such a
thing you can see for yourself
we've lost our fear of the sun
we can create what the sun does on earth
and we're not afraid of it anymore
look i can't easily talk about ukraine
at the moment because
i am so isolated from the rest of you
all
i
if i start talking about this
it becomes very clear that there
really we're distracting ourselves with
everything else and so i i understand
that we've decided to distract ourselves
to not take this seriously to trifle
with armageddon
and to have fun with it we've got a
handsome jewish guy who loves his wife
with one of the great lines of all time
you know what the line is
i need ammunition
not a ride
right and so it's like oh my god
nobody's nobody's ever done anything
that masculine and i'm kind of excited
it's like okay so now we're gonna have a
planet that is coked up on the
testosterone testosterone
of uh ukraine's head of state
and we're going to trifle with
armageddon
as if
this is fun or okay or
hey let's redo the early part of the
20th century before we had the nuclear
weapon
and
my assessment is
that
it is more likely that you are all sane
and that i am insane because of the odds
but i think it's the reverse
i think when i called for a return to
above-ground nuclear testing i saw that
the cold war wasn't over
and i saw
a
world of people whose brains had been
restructured by their phone like i'll
just give you something from miami i was
in miami was it a wonderful dinner
very successful guy picked up the tab
but when the topic came up he said you
know the thing about all out nuclear
wars i'm not really worried about all
that nuclear war i'm worried about
reestablishing credibility in the
markets afterwards
and i thought
got it
we're not i'm not in the same
conversation so i think that
to be to be blunt about it um i've gone
crazy
and i'm i'm telling you how important
above-ground nuclear testing with
radiation
um
[Music]
you know a lot of the radiation
the permanent radiation comes from the
i guess the the fission reaction that
is turned into the fusion reaction
thanks to the geometry of
teller and ulam and
i think that it is a question of
self-preservation i think you cannot
have this many people
um completely
i've gone crazy
i believe that we are trifling with
armageddon and if we get onto this topic
i will just sound like the
most
unbalanced person you've heard well i
don't think so and here's the reason why
if
we look at
the uh the writings of our mutual friend
david kaiser
the german housing professor at mit of
science technology studies a good friend
truly a wonderful individual he wrote a
book about the quantum legacy i think
it's called and it's about kind of twin
nuclei in your language but but more not
the biological nuclei but but sort of
the the contemporaneous development of
nuclear weapons
of space travel and of the interest in
aliens and uh events like roswell and so
forth that that wasn't coincidental that
they were all sort of um
synergistically related and it wasn't
purely serendipitous and his claim i
think is now being taken up as one of
the um
one of the possible explanations
of fermi's paradox so i'm going to ask
you first to define fermi's paradox and
then i'm going to read this paper which
is behind a paywall but i'm going to
give value to my audience so on this
channel we do nothing if not give value
and this is going to be a
a website which you will thank me for in
your dreams and it gets you over
paywalls uh i will reveal that in just a
minute so stay tuned for that that's
what we call foreshadowing in the
business area um first of all what is a
fermi paradox uh is is it significant
does it rise to the level of the twin
paradox of the uh
of zeno's paradox
or is it merely a stepping stone into a
bigger series of questions fermi paradox
please
well
i would rather hear it from an
astrophysicist than there happens to be
one right here so fermi did the
calculation even back in the 50s of how
many stars there were how many how
likely it was to have uh life and other
planets sort of precursor to what's
called the drake equation
and he came up with this estimate based
on the very large number of stars known
in the milky way galaxy even at that
point not taking into account galaxies
outside of the milky way
and he said the overwhelming odds are
that there are uh other civilizations
other aliens
and so he asked one of these questions
after the calculations that he was
famous for the so-called fermi
calculations he said where are they you
know if the odds are there's tremendous
numbers of these civilizations of
advanced extraterrestrial technology
capable species not slime mold um you
know oh by the way eric you know i i
wanted to ask this of my friends on
twitter but i i'm too scared to ask it
so i'll ask it of you if we found an
embryo like a human fetus you know let's
say it's uh three months development
gestation and it's on the planet you
know pro scion b
you know trappist one uh what do you
think the the these the community of
astronomers would do
i mean would they say ah it's nothing
you know let's
let's abort it i mean is that a is that
an interesting litmus test to you of how
we would react if we saw a fetus
whatever age you want to say 10 days 20
days it has a heartbeat it's just
sitting there on some planet and some
exosolar planet
is that relevant to the conversation of
abortion at all
i i don't even know it's like a
boltzmann brain but it's a sportsman
eater
boltzmann fetus
whatever you're smoking you've not sent
me any of it uh i did see an enormous
mushroom the other day that on on your
channel and uh this is an exciting new
direction for middle ages never lick the
mushroom never lick the mushroom um look
we seem to be very afraid to believe
and
you know let me just get over the hump
i don't believe we're the only life in
the universe i don't know how common or
how
rare it is i don't know whether or not
there are ways of
evading i don't know whether einstein's
restrictions pass through to all
successor theories to relativity
um
you know
einstein may have done something to
newton but he didn't do everything to
newton's conservation laws if you know
properly understood
so
we don't know
what the source of our apparent
aloneness
is
but a parent may be doing a fair amount
of heavy lifting
and and what i've offered up is the
fermi paradox that i know
the only fermi paradox that i know is
the one on north sentinel island in the
andaman chain
because the islanders
are effectively indians but they don't
know that they're indians
they may not even know that india exists
or that india claims north sentinel
island
or that it won't let anyone land there
and
my other claim
is that
i believe that a good chunk of humanity
has
um
stumbled
into a very appealing wrong idea so
first i want to talk about the appeal of
the wrong idea
the wrong idea is
the more we find out the more we realize
how little we understand there's
something like really comforting about
this
you know and imagine that you you apply
this generally like you know the longer
i'm in love the more i realize how
little i understand about the human
heart oh that's beautiful but then you
apply it to real things like
the longer i study continental
exploration the more i realize that
every new land mass
we find on earth is just an indication
of how many land masses we have yet to
find
that's like the dumbest thing you could
possibly say but has the same basic
feeling
well i think we're almost at the end
i think
we are afraid to say
something which has always been false in
the past now
the thing is
we're almost at the end of the rules of
physics
when
somebody says that everyone says yeah
lord kelvin said that
they thought that that was true when
they had the proton and the electron and
then they found the neutron okay well
yes and it was always true that powered
human flight was never going to happen
because it had never happened until it
happened
and it was the same thing you know there
was this land mass off of siberia that i
think was discovered in the 20th century
which is the last major land mass to be
found
nobody's worried about the idea that
there are
uncharted desert isles uh on earth
because we have the satellite
we're about at the end of physics i
think
now that could be wrong
the easy ways easiest way for it to be
wrong is that we would be at the end of
this chapter but it would be a book with
many chapters you have to finish this
chapter to know that there are chapters
to follow okay
what if for the moment
i take the contrarian position and say
no no i think this is about to wrap up
and the really weird thing is is that
it's taken
from 1945 until the present
for us to get close
that's a
the blink of an eye in cosmic time
but my belief is is that if anything is
monitoring us and if i'm not wrong
right before you have the full power of
the laws of physics
you let off a nuke
and then you go from fission diffusion
and so the concern that i have is first
of all that the fermi paradox on north
sentinel island
is the same as the fermi paradox we have
here on earth where we are in the north
sentinelese and we're trying to guess
that india exists
so my question to you is first of all is
there some sort of a thing that doesn't
want us contact that is shielding us
the way india shields north sentinel
island and is it the case that whatever
it is is you know while we think oh well
geez sam harris my friend said
whoever
is out there must be you know
millions of years and more advanced they
they would view us as aphids
nonsense
um
there is probably
a
level of sophistication where
it kind of taps out
and you know you can build bigger and
bigger computers but you're not going to
discover more land masses on earth and i
don't know that you're going to discover
more laws of physics
i'm concerned quite honestly that we've
lost our fear of the cosmos just the way
we've lost our fear of nukes
we've become relatively certain that
nothing ever happens here that we won't
be visited that there's no
there's nothing else other than us
and i'm worried that what we did is we
alerted whatever is out there hey we're
just about at the end and we're we
haven't worked out our stuff and we're
going to be able to get off this rock if
you are able to get off this rock
i mean to come visit this rock rather so
if things can visit us we can leave
now it may be that all the planets are
you know rushing away from each other um
because of the expansion of the metric
of space like splices and slices in the
universe
but
if the next theory has the power
to get us really far really easily and
far might be in many dimensions not all
of them spatial
i would be very worried that whatever is
watching us
knows how close we are
so i mean we have to admit the mastodon
in the room is that we have no evidence
there's life elsewhere i stole that from
sir roger penrose uh that they're you
know they're and and we hear this lee
cronin and uh my friend near
sarah walker you know they were just on
lex and they're they're talking very
very specifically about the traits and
characteristics of these aliens and what
they're going to be like and how you can
calculate exactly how much structure
went into them and how you could detect
them and they're molly and it's all very
interesting and it's rooted in sound
chemical and physical reasoning uh but
there's still this huge you know lacuna
which is that there's zero evidence and
in fact i want to try an uh i want to
try something out on you an argument
that i have which will sound dirty uh
but it's not and you know it's not uh
and it's called panspermia
panspermia okay now it sounds dirty but
it involves the exchange of material
between planets in our solar system and
other uh solar systems perhaps and uh
you talked to avi loeb our mutual friend
uh not too long ago in miami also while
he was uh uh uh uh down there with you
um and uh he talked about the uh almost
you know definite admission by the us
government that uh an extraterrestrial
meteorite uh had landed from another
solar system in the somewhere in the
ocean on earth and uh and that was
obtained and i love avi i'm you know
like you you know kind of helping him
out on his project galileo uh so we're
both you know kind of obvi uh
maximalists uh to use mixed metaphors
but avi uh you know claims this is there
and it's based on trajectory data highly
controversial people you know can't
reproduce it but at any rate it if true
highlights the fact that materials such
as this meteorite i've given you several
of these and you tried to snort one once
anyway these are meteorites they come
from argentina they're delivered the by
gravity and the us postal service
they're hard iron silicon and cobalt
they're highly magnetic
and they came and they smashed into
earth now there are meteorites that i
will never give to you because they cost
as much as my first you know two cars
put together uh i have and it came from
the planet mars so i have a chunk of
mars in my uh in my lab and that chunk
of mars was proven by gas chromatography
and other tools to originate from mars
okay now how did it get here same way
blasted off of mars by a martian
meteorite kicked around the solar system
for a few million years landed on earth
in northwest africa now the same process
happens in reverse life
carrying molecules could be embedded on
rocks and you know chunk of a whale gets
kicked out into space and then
eventually lands on mars right but we
have no evidence of that we have no
evidence of that happening over billions
of years now this could this could this
has been happening as long as life has
been on earth which lee and others tell
me is four billion years so you have
four billion years of opportunity to
have panspermic transfers of
life that we know exist on earth going
to other parts of our solar system and
there's zero evidence not you know i'm
not asking for terraformed you know
plateaus on venus just saying there's no
evidence now absence of evidence isn't
proof of of absence but um you shouldn't
at some point people start to take the
lack of of you know any sort of data or
what what have you as as troubling in a
bayesian sense that you can't put a
prior that is so certain close to 100
percent lee tells me that he believes
aliens are inevitable and you sound like
you believe it as well so i want to ask
you what level what would it take you to
believe that aliens don't exist
alien life forget about intelligence
just life anywhere in the universe
anywhere else in the universe what would
i mean what would i have to ask what
what piece of evidence would you have to
have to know that's impossible that you
know it's impossible for life to be
elsewhere than earth
impossible
oh there's
vanishingly vanishingly small in other
words the people that say it's
guaranteed like avi and lee and maybe
you i don't know uh say it's it's all
but guaranteed the fermi you know kind
of suggestion is all but guaranteed uh
so what series of pieces of evidence
would decrease that to as close to zero
as you could imagine you can't rule it
out obviously
oh you're going to hate this answer
we would get to the next level in
physics we would find out that it does
give us the ability to buzz the cosmos
we would send out an enormous number of
probes
and
we would
change our base we would tutor our
bayesian prior by
exploring all of the
most earth-like exoplanets we could find
which are now cheap to visit because of
new discoveries
that were not
available to us when we were stuck with
einstein's effective theory or quantum
field theory
that was what it would take
right now i can't see
almost anything really i mean i can't
get you beyonce but i can get you to see
i can get you the speed of light right
we can have a
discussion about the simulation
hypothesis and that we can have avatars
cruising about the universe we don't see
any evidence of that either as uh in
contrast to my guest david schalmer's
claim uh you know so so i mean we could
travel at the speed of light isn't that
good enough
do we really have to go beyond the speed
of light before you believe that they
don't exist
you know brian i don't know how to think
about this there's a suite of problems
that is different than any problem we've
ever solved in science one of them would
be the beginning
how did life begin that would be an
example of the class of problems i want
to talk about or another one of these
would be
how do you get consciousness to evolve
from the material world
another of these would be contact or the
ability to prove
where did the
origin of the universe
what is the origin of the universe what
is behind the surface of last scattering
why do men and women take so much
such different times when going to the
restroom you know
they're very reasonable
what there's some things man is not
meant to know literally exactly that's
what i was trying to say with the
surface of last scattering
um
i i believe that
we haven't solved any of these problems
ever
the hardest things that we know how to
do
all right look the hardest thing that i
know is quantum field theory
and
quantum field
have you tried wordle
no i've not tried it
um
quantum field theory is
unbelievably difficult to learn
and it has gotten
harder and easier now i have the entire
standard model in stylized form
that animates
uh
you know this is the classical input
that when quantized gives us our
understanding of the world and it's
incredibly simple the idea that this
fits on a mug
is and and you and i can go line by line
symbol by symbol and say what everything
is grand drinkification
the um
we have only solved problems in the
shallow end of science we have never
solved a problem outside of the shallow
end of science
and so when people start to talk about
like free will i just think wow
you've gone from
you know wearing floaties in the shallow
end with your parents holding you up
to wanting to
surf shark infect infested waters
uh you know off the coast of portugal
with monster waves and you know sharp
rocks or who knows what it's like it's a
totally different level of science
to figure out life's origin or
consciousness or the beginning of the
universe we haven't gotten to any of
these yet
and i think what we're very good at is
we're very good at extremely hard simple
problems
so we're all interested in these
questions
but my interest isn't in the
recreational version of these i know
that if you and i did nothing else other
than talk about free will for a year
we would get nowhere if we
we the conversation would be
recreational we'd have nothing we'd have
no choice but to get nowhere we would
have
i think we could have many different
possible conversations none of them will
get anywhere
so i'm always curious as to why people
say i believe in free will i don't okay
so you're gonna do that thing
um
we need to do things that might work and
the things that might work have to do
with like you know my friend rima khan
is about to have her seti meeting
uh in san francisco you know we can
listen for things we can try to work on
the laws of physics i cannot believe we
are still focused on rockets
but very rich people seem to like
rockets if they have any idea of the
danger where we're in here on earth i
think it's a completely
bizarre
feature of wealth and and brilliance
that brilliant smart people choose
rockets don't know why
um
we got to do something
and we've never solved any of these
problems and i don't think we're going
to get to these problems by
pretending i mean i
i always want when somebody talks to me
about what life will be like
to bring up cephalopods
if i look at a cuttlefish and i look at
how intelligent a cuttlefish is maybe
not as smart as an octopus
but a cuttlefish is such an alien
creature it's so far away from us on the
phylogenetic tree
that it proves that you can't really
easily anticipate what smart looks like
it's probably the reason that the
heptapods were used in that movie what
is it a rival
yeah
um and i think that the next physical
theory
is gonna blow our
minds i think we've sat so long
pretending to have our minds blown by
entanglement and schrodinger's cat and
you know the fact that you get thinner
and heavier
you know
in relativity theory whatever
terrible paradox
um
that uh
that's not really the mind-blowing stuff
what's about to come
i think is going to
rewrite our knowledge of ourselves just
the way dna did
so so pitch me omilan you know
i can uh take 44 billion dollars and put
it towards twitter
i can uh scrap it and uh put or even you
know make it 43 billion dollars
what do you tell him
what should he do what would you do he
knows i mean what would i do i mean he's
a physics major he was a u-pen uh i mean
more than a physics major he's evidenced
i think continuing interest in physics
but he has hijacked the conversation of
getting off the planet
which should be a conversation about
many many many many many many different
experiments rather than the moon and
mars
and getting off with physics to being a
conversation about rockets so anytime
you talk about diversifying existential
risk to humans
someone will now say oh don't worry bro
elon's gonna get us to mars
with those awesome awesome rockets it's
just like
i don't understand this so i i can't
pitch elon so
i mean but but again to push back with
respect as you know i always do and i
cheerfully uh recognize that i may have
a huge blind spots myself but it seems
to me as if you're going back to 1491
and you're telling you know queen
esmeralda or whoever
don't fund this guy chris uh chris c uh
don't
he's just
that doesn't make sense we should do
rockets
okay we shouldn't obsess about rockets
right not rockets only in the portfolio
but but again let me just finish my
torture analogy because it took me like
a half an hour to make it up in the
shower this morning uh but uh you know
are you telling her uh we should really
fund this guy you know yitzhak newton uh
or you know to get these laws that will
actually take us to the moon uh you know
let's just skip ahead boats forget about
these barks and and uh and boats let's
galleons let's skip ahead um i don't
know that that would actually get us
where we want to go right because
you're saying
you know this your priors are going to
be informed uh by the either an a no go
theorem that says we can't go beyond
einstein in which case what would you
say there are no aliens
if if we couldn't go beyond einstein
yeah we're trapped in no word
like
this is another problem which is that
einstein hijacked the conversation so
that now every time we talk it's like no
dude
we have time dilation we have wormholes
it's like we have
oh no i thought you were making him a
crypto enthusiast with laser eyes that's
right einstein with laser eyes i told
him
okay
okay
so um
i don't think elon shouldn't do rockets
i think rockets is a profitable business
and i think getting people excited about
the future has to do with going back to
the last moment when we actually as a
country
you know
we didn't want to say let's develop
icbms that are really efficient in uh
hitting beijing and moscow we said
we choose to go to the moon
and
um okay so you know true enough
so go to the moon but stop with the
terraforming and mars of the in the the
light of human civilization i just
you have to actually want to save
us from ourselves right now
and talk about it in order to realize
how completely crazy elon has made
everyone who listens to him because at
the moment
if you had einstein and you had elon
people would be gravitating to elon
he's charismatic he's now in a world
which is not comfortable with masculine
traits
he's highly chaotic he's very
entertaining
and people have this idea like yo dude
he's the richest man in the world bro
and that's the currency of our time
so my feeling about this is everyone
elon reaches with the story of
terraforming mars with rockets and all
this kind of stuff
thinks that's the plan
and
i just think it's
it's completely crazy to
get
everything right and then go rockets
terraform and mars right at the end and
just like
dude i just read this entire
you know war and peace length novel and
then the last page you just
you just do something completely bizarre
i just don't get it
maybe i'm dumb maybe i don't i don't
understand i don't think it's ferdinand
and isabella i think that they you know
we needed to fund universities that
studied natural philosophy and and
mathematics and physics and we needed to
explore the world because we didn't know
what was here
and we should go to mars and we should
go to the moon and we should have i if
somebody said our rocket allocation is
stupid we should take it to zero
i would be fighting tooth and nail to
make sure that rockets are budgeted for
okay
the emphasis on rockets is psychotic
it's it's like you're looking at a
portfolio of a very very rich person
that's only in one municipal bond or
something
and you're like respect make make this
make sense
yeah he is uh but then of course he is
you know more diversified neurologically
than almost anybody
uh we can i'm just saying that he
doesn't have the right to hijack the
rock that the
we need to spread out and diversify
because we're going to get ourselves
killed on one planet with a shared
atmosphere
it's completely unreasonable for him
it's it's wonderful
i mean i just i have a very clear idea
that he's one of the smartest most
forward thinking people and he's got a
rocket company and he's talking in some
sense his book
right and he knows look
i don't know him
but i almost
i almost feel like i can guarantee you
he knows better
and so you know i don't want to
speculate on what his strategy is but he
knows better than to bet everything on
mars terraforming and the moon with
rockets
right now um pivoting maybe slightly
away we look at um
you know what what
we could do you pointed to one thing in
there you mentioned universities and how
important they were now in 1492
the university system was only about 400
years old at that point and and it's
it's aged since then and starting in
1080 or so in bologna
uh and very little has changed and i
wonder you know
the best and the brightest
so to speak what they might be getting
sucked up into this orbit of elan no pun
intended or this this kind of thinking
or many other things crypto
but at least people like michael saylor
who i had on the show last year uh is
very gracious and
and forward thinking as well um
you know he started sailor academy and
that's sort of a university that only is
going to produce stem majors not going
to produce you know
gender studies majors and it's not going
to produce uh things that are not
related to pure science technology
engineering and math because he believes
that we need you know a million phds in
in these fields in order for us to
progress and actually i think the i
think the limiting factor for elon is
going to be uh humans it's not going to
be robots it's not going to be capital
it's going to be having enough people
and and so the the fault that i have for
him is that
i don't see any and i'm not saying oh
give you know
yesterday a billion 100 million dollars
was given to stanford university for
sustainability i'm not even saying elon
you know hook ucf steve up with uh with
the musk institute and we'll turn out
your p because i don't think i can do it
either uh is that is there fundamental
limitation for us getting off the planet
in your language uh or becoming
interplanetary in his language or
transcending the laws of physics in your
language getting off the planetary
species in his life is it humans and is
it solvable because i can't just
nucleate as good as i am i can't just
nuclear get out of the vacuum kids
well but okay so let's look at the very
weird question of
anybody with a halfway interesting
version of a theory beyond the standard
model and i don't mean
sorry
i'm going to be very careful about the
phrasing
we have large programs
grand unification super symmetry
technicolor super strings etc
these are the big programs
more or less if you're not on a big
program i know of almost no one inside
the university system
who's got a truly
interesting audacious
idea
for what to do next
i could tell you
that you know peter white for example
has moved from being a curmudgeon to
actually saying this i believe which is
fascinating i mean imagine if sabine
hassenfelder
instead of complaining about
the gobbledygook or the fact that people
are actually you know and she's quite
accurate i think about this overselling
things that don't work
but
i really love that peter
moved towards saying this is what i
think
may be generating all of this
he's there in a non-traditional role
inside of the math department of
columbia university he's writing books
he's writing papers he's giving talks
but he's not a professor
same thing with
you know
david deutsch has a really weird
situation at oxford garrett lisey has a
very weird situation wherever he is
julian barbour has a weird situation
stephen wolfram
inside the
universities we've
turned it into the hunger games
academically and so everyone is worried
about survival and nobody's actually
worried about physics because they're
worried about personal survival they're
not worried about general survival
i think what you have to look at is that
there is a reluctance i mean
one of the things i say that doesn't win
me a ton of friends is it appears that
nobody actually has any money
and
the reason that i say that is that all
sorts of it it feels to me like nobody
uh
we have rockef there was there were
rockefellers they built rockefeller
university and the university of chicago
one of our absolute jewels um you know
vanderbilt there's a vanderbilt
university carnegie had money there's a
kearney
layla and stanford
we don't want
to invest anymore in this stuff
there's a general anti-science thing
partially i think fueled by the fact
that when anthony fatchi says i am the
science trust the science
we we science
we are revolt
we recoil in order maybe i should say it
that way and
i think people who have money
are turning away from universities
because
those containers
are seemingly very susceptible
to revolutionary nonsense
and so why would you build
a container and then put great stuff in
it only to have it instantly corrupted
by the
dean of niceness goodness and fluffy
puppy dogs for uh
pediatric oncology patients you know
it's like okay
we need to help kids who are facing
cancer
we need i love i have a dog i like good
things ice cream blah blah blah blah
but
the university is attesting to their own
fundamental goodness at every turn and
denouncing everyone who disagrees with
them
as genghis khan hitler or
lizzie borden or whatever
it's not a very appealing
pitch
to people with resources so what i'm
seeing is that more or less people with
incredible resources
don't want to spend
on things that are important
they've been tinged with this kind of
failure and greediness and
my my you know
brian you're doing something um
okay
i
i think
one of the things we need to do is if if
if the government is just going to
renege on the endless frontier compact
between the universities and the federal
government
i don't want to be in a
intellectual property category where we
can't monetize what we discover
i just want to take you by your ankles
and say god damn it you fooled us give
us all our money back that we generated
for you we built the entire economy and
you treat us
like we're your servants you're making
me sick to my stomach for god's sakes
grow a pair
and recognize you've got the world's
greatest deal and that these people
basically have integrity and you're
turning their lives upside down into a
horror
where people don't want to go in to
their offices and universities and you
know when i was just touring
universities on the east coast
professors would close their doors and
in hush tones they would say you know i
can't really say this outside but things
have gotten really crazy here and i'm
thinking
you're the owners of the university no
matter what anyone tells you you don't
want to send your kid to a university
that isn't run effectively by its
professors
universities are not
primarily about teaching you should go
to a college if you're focused on
teaching universities are about research
and the research is done by professors
and by far the most research
the most important research is done in
stem
i mean i think there's very important
research that's been done in folklore
ethnomusicology was something i
considered going into
there's plenty of things that can be
researched that aren't stem
but the most important things we do
is to
better understand the world in which we
live gain power and wisdom to control it
and if the humanities aren't going to be
giving us wisdom but are going to be
giving us negative wisdom
it's very important that anybody with
hate in their heart who talks about
anti-racism all day long which is just
another name for racism
should not be informing people who might
have to make nuclear weapons or fuel air
explosives or any one of the horrible
things
that we may need to keep ourselves
safe
it's very important to keep lunatics
away from the stuff that actually works
and i mean i i i've always agreed with
you in in general terms um
but i do feel like uh we have uh kind of
an opportunity that is only
you know kind of
full of latency when it's uh thought
prospectively in the future in other
words the inventor of the laser you know
uh charlie towns or the inventor of you
know gps and things like that or
einstein these these people died you
know not not wealthy people
uh and and yet if they had attempted and
and yet the the creator of ethernet you
know their three com
you know is currently uh
in what terms bran wealthy financially
so okay now we can define wealth other
ways obviously but let's let's let's
pause that just for one second
i'm going to disagree in very strong
terms
i went into academics
in large measure for freedom
and that's why people go into business
for freedom
i think that if you priced the freedom
that somebody like noam chomsky enjoyed
you know probably had his pension taken
care of probably was made an institute
professor at mit could draw off on any
topic he had this giant
army behind him that would stand up for
his freedom of expression and freedom of
inquiry
the functional equivalent
of noam chomsky's wealth was absolutely
enormous oh sure i'm not debating that
and you couldn't have by the way you can
have both elan you know dictates you can
have both you can have intellectual
capital as well but i'm thinking purely
for the translational ability of wealth
to then be used to research purposes so
you made the argument that we should
have taxed you know uh semiconductor
instructions or emails all of which are
invented by physicists or no we
shouldn't have done that we should have
kept our agreements but if you're going
to be a prick about it right by by all
means you're basically
taking everything that was developed by
people that you'd now treat as your
servants
um who you've actually legally hobbled
and my feeling about this is that's
completely unethical
100 all i'm saying is that uh the
biggest lie in finance is that past
performance isn't indicative of future
you know returns i mean look at uh look
at whatever pick whatever pre-dot-com
company you like so all i'm saying is
that given that academia academicians
like the ones that you mentioned have
been treated like garbage and that
physicists have not been able to not
monetize for our selfish own internal
purposes which i believe we deserve but
i'm not going to talk about that for the
purpose of physics for the greater glory
of physics i claim we need to start with
an educational campaign now in other
words when you say the next project
that's going to be developed quantum
computing or before it's monetized and
we lose the rights to say hold on i
didn't sign off on this ip we need to be
smart and i don't think there's any
training you know certainly i'm guilty i
don't train my graduates since i'm
blessed to have so many brilliant i
never sit down sorry if you ever get
into a situation i have two patents by
the way i never sit down and say like if
i'm ever in the situation where this
thing could make you know millions of
like here's what i should do in order to
benefit but i think we need something it
should be in some way incorporate into
our education and i think the best way
to do that ironically is through the
humanities show through history of
physics as you know better than anybody
although i always say it's if you want
to if you want to damn somebody with
fake praise as a scientist you say he's
really knowledgeable about the history
of physics you know it's like it's such
a such a backhanded compliment but you
do in all honesty and all seriousness
you do understand it you articulate it
back on that because that's kind of a
dig
my feeling about this is you don't need
to know the history of physics if you
want to do relatively workmanlike
scientific research
the only people who really need to
understand the history of physics aren't
most physicists it's the tiny number of
people who are going to do things like
break new ground
so
it's really important not to sell the
history of physics to everybody you can
become a calculational monkey
and go to any calculational monkey
school and do calculational monkey
equations that's fine
the really hard thing is to try to
figure out how did people break out of
cognitive prisons
and so you know
some of the
funniest things is when people have
these insults
like uh like the one you just said it's
like well yeah because you didn't
understand what it was about to begin
with
yeah i i agree i guess all i'm saying is
wouldn't it be great to have education
so that the next time we invent the
internet you know hypertext protocols uh
that we can think for a second that how
do we do this how do we renegotiate the
contract that's what i want to say
you're you're very astute you picked up
on the problem but we can't go back and
rectify the past performance but we can
say given the way that the history of
the field is gone you when you invent
the the uh the quantum you know beam uh
the bose-einstein condensate laser uh
that will be used for god knows what uh
before you do that we should have an
honest conversation about or crispr or
whatever
where are the mega fortunes
that are interested in this stuff
and my claim is um
you know we both talked to jim simons
jim knows how important this stuff is
and he's put a fair amount of capital
behind this
in my you know at some point i had a
conversation with him
about fixing education
and he said i spent a fair amount of
time on it and the only thing that
actually seemed to make sense is to take
terrible teachers and make them slightly
less terrible
and it was just it was a heartbreaking
thing
so i've seen people plow money into some
of these things and get very little back
yeah um
[Music]
the things that work
can't be said very easily right now
because they're out of keeping with the
ethos of our time
um you meet people he's like how do you
know who's good
um
because you talk to them
you find out whether they have 12 ideas
before
they have a cup of coffee and three of
them are good
you know
three good ideas that's astounding it's
hard to have good ideas
we basically know who's good
and
we don't get to dial their facial
characteristics or look at their
chromosomes or whatever
you know
good is good
um
famously ramanujan was uh
you know sent a letter to hardy and he
and little hardy and littlewood read it
in cambridge and they said well
um
either he's a humbug or a genius and we
guessed genius because humbugs are
relatively rare
beautiful one um
we know who's good we know who to fund
and we know how to leave people alone
and nobody wants to do it everybody
wants to say oh it's all in the ethos
and the myth of the lone individual and
you know this is so elitist all this
kind of nonsense okay well
i don't know how to tell you this but
you just you're wrong twelve thousand
ways from sunday and you're gonna
destroy everything that we know how to
do
many of the people who make real
breakthroughs um are very difficult to
deal with
and if you don't want to deal with
people who are difficult to deal with
you can just sort of write off most
progress right yeah i mean i wouldn't
leave feynman alone with my
daughter or your daughter
uh but uh but he sure knew his way uh
that's true because we don't want
feynman macedo or kicked in the groin
because he's a valuable human being
and our kids are skilled in the deadly
arts of the groin attack from krav maga
training that we give them and that is a
mitzvah for you
yes exactly uh so we're talking with
eric weinstein proprietor of the portal
podcast among other things you can find
eric at eric r weinstein at both twitter
and on instagram he has a website uh it
was about a year ago we had a
conversation about geometric unity
and i want to talk about that uh because
it's still it's still it haunts my
dreams it's still something that's very
delightful and uh and it represents uh a
sort of a sort of you know candle in the
darkness a sort of hope uh scream in the
void uh thinking big things uh obviously
it's not uh you know if there are there
are people that have as you mentioned
peter white garrett lisey uh they're
they're a surf fight of of other uh
contender theories that have their own
lacunae but uh where where where are you
now with with geometric unity where is
the project at this point
well i'm talking to a lot more different
physicists um
who have you met with most recently
that's the most exciting for you besides
present company obviously
well i mean i don't get any details but
i think probably one of the best
conversations i had recently
might have been with nima
arkani ahmed
there's a local
graduate student
i'm going to
mention his name because he deserves it
and what is the name to watch trevor
sharpener
at ucla is an unbelievable
up and coming guy in i think zv burns
group
but i've been you know talking with avi
about astrophysics
discussed
with alan guth recently um some aspects
of
uh
how
multiple generations are generated um
just
a fairly
colleagues in france
i've been i've been very lucky to have
access to great people and i think that
one of the things that's happened is
that
with supersymmetry
and
with string theory not being able to
find something that that really shows us
that they're on the right track
um
people are slowly
open to the idea of either shutting
high energy
fundamental physics down and i
it's good people are going to be
up in arms about that there's like a
huge move to move towards
quantum computation
you say why is that it's like oh well
because computers have been really
important and so the metaphor of the
universe as a computer is really
important
um
information power maybe we can rebase
everything around information
it's
something you can do you can try
but i think right at the moment
where we are is that
[Music]
we realize
that the baby boomer
program
has
run its course the baby boomer program
was strings
almost all of the people
in string theory
came up
they viewed the world a particular way
they changed the problems that we
thought of as fundamental
uh quantizing gravity uh became the
the problem to work on which i think was
absolutely wrong
and what we find ourselves in is a world
in which
the old thing that was crowding out
everything else is in the process of
dying and that is string fundamentalism
one of the great things about talking to
nima
was
for me
that
nima is not captured by strings but he's
animated by strings which is the exactly
the right position to be in which is
that you're not
100 sure that strings are the right
direction to go but you can say look at
all of the things that string theory
accomplishes inside of quantum field
theory it gives us paradigmatic
um ways in which we can elude certain
seemingly no-go theorems and the like or
it's taught us a lot and i think that
the toy theories that really came along
with the string guys because the string
guys
they are mostly guys um
not 100 but
too much
more or less uh
used a lot of toy quantum field theories
to explore some of these ideas that was
a sort of a second program that was very
good by the way
on their part for developing quantum
field theory as a discipline
but it's been a disaster for uncovering
new physical law and new physical
explanations
so i do think that right at the moment
um people would be open but there's no
we should be building accelerators we
should be getting people here's the
crazy thing brian
i'm dancing around and trying not to say
it but maybe i'll just say it we just
had this w
mass announcement
the w particle appears to be much
heavier
and by much i don't mean like three
times as heavy but i mean
by
an appreciable amount heavier than we
thought
and i watch everyone's explanations of
this to the public
and i haven't seen one that really
sounds to me like what this thing
actually is
we settle on these here's how we talk to
the public about the w masses
well what is the w particle it's more or
less a part of a derivative from
calculus
and what does a derivative want to do
it wants to differentiate functions well
what functions does it have
well it can differentiate something
called a higgs field
now if you look
at this mug for example i'm not good at
going around drinking and arriving
drinking and deriving
that term right there which probably
looks like
d sub mu of phi norm squared
that term
is where the w particle
interacts with the higgs particle
so you're effectively using the w
particle to differentiate a higgs
particle just the way you use the photon
to differentiate an electron
that process
by which the higgs particle gives mass
to
a small number of pieces of a derivative
the w and z particles it gives mass in
some sense to itself
um you've got this potential term here
you've got yukawa terms here where it's
giving mass the same phi is occurring
here
uh
all of i'm sorry
not
hold that up so this is where the
w particles getting mass this is where
the higgs is getting mass from itself
through its interaction with the mexican
hat potential the sombrero
yeah the yukawa term where the the
fermions the electrons and protons get
mass
that whole system isn't explained to
anybody in the public
which is criminal and you know and then
i've sort of been in this kind of
self-examination phase which is people
say oh eric you use so many big words
why can't you understand mark we can't
we understand you it's like well
one thing is almost nobody's actually
trying to tell you what's really going
on
and when i sit there and i say okay the
w particle is part of a derivative
all my colleagues know what i'm saying
but they're not venturing out there to
say something so simple and i don't know
why they're not doing it so the public
isn't animated
like the fact is this mug
if you had this mug in your house and
you said somebody says let me tell you
more or less everything other than
gravity is on that mug
somebody would want to know
one person in your family like well how
do i read it what does it mean what are
the different terms do they have names
nobody is talking to the public
about what it is that we do
and that's how i get into trouble i say
you know hey i have an explanation for
why there are three generations of
matter
i don't even know that's a problem
okay
so if you think about the sort of things
that gu is doing different than let's
say garrett or or peter white
one of the things i think that's
exciting is is that a good theory should
probably tell the standard model in
general relativity what it got wrong
and i don't think anybody inside of the
academic system wants to do that they
want to extend only
you know this is why for example
everybody will add sterile neutrinos to
the standard model because it's like
it's the least offensive thing that
won't screw anything up
so i've been thinking a lot about this
which is why do why do none of us talk
to the public in real terms why do we
allow
feynman's dumbest statements to
characterize
what seems to be the height of
sophistication if you can't if you can't
explain it to your grandma it means you
don't understand if i can't create the
word world myself
then then i'm useless it's like okay
well it's a lot of machismo but it's not
very smart
and
in those
in those opportunities none of us are
really filling it in we're not talking
about what the w particle is we're not
talking about why it's important we're
not talking about why this is so
exciting i can hardly sleep i don't know
i don't even know that it's real maybe
fight it may be wrong
well we know things are real we know
calculus is real and let's start with a
you know when i learned calculus i had
to self teach it to myself because i
actually wasn't placed along a math
track that would have taken me to take
the aps and i had to kind of
self-motivate and that came because of a
love of astronomy that i wanted to find
out well how do we know these galaxies
are moving away how do we know hayley's
comets orbit and all sorts of things
that were going on at the time when i
was a you know pre-teen and so i had to
teach it myself but once i learned it
i kind of felt like i had you know
gotten the cheat code you know just i
started to see things in a different way
and i went through the portal and at
that moment
i felt a great gift had been given to me
and it was given by myself but in the
sense that i was given these gifts from
the great people that came before me
including my hero galilei
galileo galilei who i want to talk about
because i have exciting news about a
wonderful project that i've been uh
blessed to work on last couple of years
now and it's come to fruition um but uh
but i feel like we're doing a disservice
that's why i say i kind of joke in the
past but i'm getting more and more
serious i feel the scientists like me
especially like me who get paid by the
public
have a moral obligation to
teach the most exciting and most
delightful delicious developments to the
public for free and they should do that
as part of their as part of their job
quote unquote and they'll say i'm not
good at it and to which i'll say oh yeah
i forgot when you were born you knew
quantum field theory oh no i had to
learn that it was very hard and it's
very sophisticated okay so you spend
time on things you think are valuable
right my fellow professors and it
doesn't make me popular around the
faculty club but i do believe that you
know especially but and every professor
every scientist is supported by the
public at some level or another so you
know we have a we have a huge we have a
branding problem we talked about the
marketing problem but we also have kind
of a um an education and a and a self
obligation that scientists don't feel we
feel like we can sit around be the be
the equation monkeys that you were
talking about before it's not true brian
i i just i mean i disagree with this
here's the basic problem because i've
gone through this now let's imagine you
want to understand what the w particle
is in the higgs particle and why this
matters right
so there's some safe thing that everyone
can say and then you can try to actually
be real and then get attacked
so i don't like being attacked it's
i've got idiots who follow me around who
call up my colleagues and try to
alienate everyone for me and my feeling
about these people is
once
you understand what the cost is you
understand why nobody does it but
here here's a chord okay this chord
represents a function
the height
of the chord is a function
and the w particle
is
in part a level
and that level could be horizontal
or we could use the level to define what
is horizontal
right and so if i pick this we all know
that the derivative is the rise over run
above that level
but
if i say you know what i have fiat power
and i'm going to decide that not this
but this is level
then the chord that is tangent at that
point is actually constant even though
it appears to be rising
okay
now i didn't use any big words
you're watching the con eric's showing
off eric is doing this
it's like in the comments people are
saying eric please write a book about
this
well some most of them but my point is
a tiny number of people who are terrible
and who just don't want good things to
happen
don't want us to try and fumble in front
of the public
and they don't want us to succeed
because then we get large follower
counts and it's like well why is that
guy
the most you know followed mathematician
on twitter it's like that should be me
okay maybe it should be you i i'll tell
you the one thing if you really have
enemies wish them fame i promise you
they want it
you don't want it it's it's a great deal
um
what we need to do is to be
more
courageous about saying
look you're not going to understand
quantum field theory but here's some
things you can break out if you can keep
up with the kardashian you can you can
keep up with quarks
you can keep up with hadrons and leptons
there aren't so many there aren't so
many hadrons and leptons that you can't
learn them all in an afternoon
right they're probably about as many
fundamental particles as there are
kardashians
and
the idea that we don't talk about this
we don't traffic and we're not excited
about this
think about 90 years ago it was this is
the 90th year anniversary of the neutron
we didn't know that there were neutrons
so my aunt
who is in her late 90s
grew up before there were neutrons so
when she was a very little girl nobody
knew what a neutron was almost
immediately after the discovery of
neutrons we get chain reactions we get
atomic weapons and atomic power
that
discovery within living memory
made the world a completely different
place and watch out for what comes next
as
an adaptation of the old saying you may
not be interested in physics but boy is
physics going to be interested in you
and
the idea that you're not part of the
conversation which is who are we what is
this place and can
we go and look at the night sky and
dream responsibly without wormholes and
without sci-fi
of visiting
if that doesn't animate you i guarantee
you you probably can't find a jimi
hendrix guitar solo that moves you
either
and that brings up the other chords that
you're capable of bringing out which are
your guitar we're going to get that at
the very end um so people in the chat
room are saying things that kim
kardashian actually has a nice set of
bosons that's kind of cool to know um
but eric uh if if actually listeners
and viewers there's 700 800 people
watching right now if you'd like eric to
write a book about this
give a thumbs up to this video and we'll
see if we can create the groundswell
necessary to do this labor of love which
is writing a book and i've actually just
produced my third
book
and i can't believe it three books in
four years
this one i didn't write so this one i
had a writer literally and the name of
the ghost
are we on the verge of a major
announcement which i don't even know
you don't know it uh it is it is a major
announcement at least in my life i've
been putting it out on twitter here and
there but now i want to come clean and
really announce it for for
all time
and that is um 390 years ago
a so 300 years before the neutron
a man by the name of galileo galilei
wrote a book that got him in a tiny bit
of hot water he was kind of the
weinstein of his day uh not afraid to be
provocative in some ways take liberties
and take a license and he wrote a book
called the dialogue and this book is in
italian is called the dialogue
and there was encounter distinction to
his first book called the sidirius
nuncius sidirius nuncius as you all know
is latin for starry messenger and he was
allowed to keep publishing in latin
because nobody spoke latin and so it
wasn't a threat to the catholic church
but after he used the spy glass as he
called it the perspective tube the
telescope
he found that he could not really get
over the overwhelming evidence that was
presented to him and he wanted to share
it for the world with the notion that
the universe is not centered on the
earth that's centered on the sun
and so he was advancing copernicus
theory and other earlier theories as
well
and he wrote this wonderful book it's
called the dialogue it's actually a
trialog between three characters uh one
of whom is modeled after galileo himself
and he gave this character the name
salviati
the
the salvation
and then the other one was modeled after
the pope pope urban uh and his arguments
and he put his arguments in the name of
a character named simplicio the
simpleton not the great you know
i love this because it shows that you
know even the most biggest geniuses and
and academia can have huge fatal flaws
in their impolitic behavior and then
there's a third character who's an
intelligent layperson his name is
sagreedo so i got the most famous two
italians that i know
carlo rivelli and fabiola giannatti
who you love for her use of comic sans
uh and so uh we
at the higgs boson announcement so we
should say that one of them is a
famous theorist is attached to loop
quantum gravity the other one is a
big shot uh
physicist
with
the
cern experiment yes the director of cern
uh which is where the lhc is located and
responsible for discovery of the higgs
boson so um we
and along with jim gates who's another
friend of yours a professor at ford
foundation professor at brown university
where i will be returning and that's
stay tuned for a top secret announcement
at the end of this month
i um have great respect for him and i've
enjoyed meeting him but we are not close
so the five or six of us uh put together
a audio book the first ever audiobook by
galileo
so it exists and you can get it wherever
books are audiobolized including amazon
audible
google play wherever you like i'll put a
link to it in the show notes below
and it was really a labor of love it
took us a year to record it edit it
in our home studios around the world in
italy carlo was in italy and in uh aches
and provence or however you pronounce
that and then my friend lucio pichurillo
is the third character we recorded it
and so much of what comes through in
this wonderful book is is just beyond
you know my comprehension as a physicist
and actually what uh oh frank wilcheck i
should say narrated uh the word and
nobel prize winner
2004 nobel prize winner for asymptotic
freedom uh he narrated the dedication by
albert einstein the forward to the book
by galileo in which he calls this book
by galileo the most important book
ever written
called galileo's book yes einstein
called the dialogue the most not not
just science book but really the most
important book uh that had really ever
been written fiction nonfiction however
you like to say it including his own
work so it was incredibly uh gratifying
to to have these people come together
and do it
and of course this book is italian and
it was written originally in italian and
we had to have a trend that was
translated um and so anyway i i started
off doing it
really kind of as a kind of a lark but
then i i decided that there could be
some spin-off opportunities not really
just for me but i think maybe for
physics and i want to get your your
impression on so one thing about this
book they're extremely expensive to get
your hands on a original copy of the
dialer 390 year old books are very rare
obviously
so i decided i have a collector friend
who allowed me to scan pictures from it
and were making nfts of it
and at first i thought it was kind of
silly kind of crazy why would you make
an nft of a physical product or whatever
but the more i thought about it like
what if we could do use blockchain
technology in science not just for
preserving or maybe maybe we could make
a dow one of these organizations these
entities to buy these books before they
get lost or stolen or whatever
you know a couple hundred thousand
dollars to get an original one
but what if we could you know either
custodialize it or if we could use it to
generate
resources for physics so i want to run
that idea by you not not specifically
with my galileo project uh but uh but
you know that's just kind of my my
testing the water with nfts uh but you
can find that on my website
briankating.com
uh uh but you know for a fraction of an
ether but what do you think about nfts
and science what do you think about the
prospects for using this blockchain
technology by any means necessary is
where i am at the moment uh
malcolm the 10th i think was correct
that we needed
to
there's certain things that are just so
important that i don't i almost don't
care how they happen my my hope is that
nfts don't backfire on us um
because
the right thing to do is to make
very serious people very rich in
autonomy so that they never
think about
you know look
making somebody a low
eight-digit millionaire double-digit
millionaire
um is probably sufficient to give them
an extremely nice life and there are
tons of those
who do far less for us than the people
who
do our molecular biology chemistry
mathematics and physics so i do think
that it's important
if we're going to abandon all of our
culture we're going to leak everything
we're going to turn the universities
into cesspools et cetera et cetera we've
got to get a few money to to the people
who
built everything for us in my opinion
those
what i don't want to see is i don't want
to see it backfiring i don't want to see
a claim oh well you guys have your nft
so you're good now it's like no
um
we're scrambling
because you screwed us over and you're
idiots and it's time for you to be
ethical and smart
that's a very hard conversation to have
if we have to dramatize it by nfts so be
it
but my feeling is what if the nft thing
goes in different directions if it goes
through to the moon
um
then it's a great move what if it goes
in the toilet and now we've we've sort
of staked our credibility
on getting involved in something that
has
a ponzi scheme
built into it i'm not saying it is a
ponzi scheme no i got it
there is ponzi in nft just as there is
genius in nft
i also want to point out that the
concept of digital scarcity if you go
back to the original blockchain white
paper of satoshi
it's very very clear that it's
propagating
something according to a conservation
law that you uh
hand me your public key and i've got my
private key and i've got this token that
i'm
laying claim to i can propagate my token
to you
in this infinite chain
of custody
by virtue of the fact that something is
conserved now of course you had to
create new tokens out of out of the
vacuum
but
my
my belief is is that one of the things
is we should be talking about this in
terms of digital conservation laws and
digital physics
and we should be active and i also think
that um
you know having been playing with the
the crypto community a little bit at
first they they dismiss everybody
because they think you come in from
outside you don't care about anything
you just want to tell people things but
we do know that
there are a lot of there's a lot of
homology between bitcoin
and gauge theory
conservation principles conservation
principles have to do with symmetry i am
sure that if you and i got roaring drunk
for two weeks
with a white board we would come up with
a symmetry principle
for bitcoin using some version of a
discretized nerders theorem
that took the conservation law that
allows us to propagate you know
satoshi's solution of the double spend
problem
is probably
worthy of some amazing science prize
it's you know just an ingenious idea
um and it's it's hard to understand like
what is the substrate of of is it the
idea that the individual wallets uh the
public private key pairs
is it uh is it computers and nodes
because you know the interesting thing
is is that it was engineered so that
nodes could go dark
and you know that's like taking a chunk
of space time out of commission
um
i think it's i think it's really
important that physics get involved
with nfts with conservation laws with
digital physics
and actually contribute into the system
to make it much more useful
and while some in the crypto community
will say oh they're just talking their
book and
to a man with a hammer everything looks
like a nail you know to a man with a
gauge theory everything looks like a
conservation law
um just ignore those people
there are so many good people in crypto
who are interested in any interesting
idea we need to party with them more
that's my thought
so i want to ask you to look into your
crystal ball and maybe we'll do the the
lightning round as we like to do eric um
all right
are we done with covid
no
explain
um
my feeling about this is that probably
kovit is much worse than we thought
or that we understand and that people
who understood it were protecting us
against something this is i don't know
this to be true if i had to make a guess
the reason that china is so ferocious
about trying to stamp covet out is that
i worry that they know something that
it's not a flu that it's a cumulative
flu that destroys you
bout by bout i don't know what this
thing is and i think it's it's criminal
that we're so far into this
and we have no idea why china is
behaving the way it's behaving or why
fauci behaves the way he behaves or
peter does
or ralph barrack or any of these people
um somehow this covet is taking place
outside of science
and it's
i'm worried that we don't understand
what kovit is
and we don't know which wave is gonna
is gonna hurt and how bad i mean
no i don't think so i think that we
decided that we're done with it because
omicron was relatively mild
but what kovid becomes next i worry that
certain people have much better
understanding than than you and i do
and that they know
why this is so dangerous i'm worried
that they the government lied twice for
different reasons
the first time i worry that they lied to
protect what they were doing with
ditra the defense threat reduction
agency
why was it working with
eco health alliance wuhan lab why under
kindly dr fauci who seems to have
something to do with a weapons portfolio
getting around a couple of treaties that
we signed and ratified in the 70s i have
no idea but i think that that was a
self-protective line and then i think
that there may have been public spirited
lying saying we if we could have told
you what it is that we created in this
uh
cauldron um
we happen to have some inside
information about this furyn cleavage
site and and the potential to attack t
cells
and the degradation why this uh binds to
so many different organs and can cross
the blood brain
i'm worried that they know that this is
a much worse disease than it appears and
that we're going to find out over time
why they were so draconian because it
does look like they wildly overreacted
not to say that people didn't die
not to say that this wasn't serious
but to shut down the world economy to
the extent that they did clearly risked
war
at some level it wasn't that it was free
and
so i'm very worried that we don't really
understand what kovit is and that
omicron seemed kind of
relatively mild but just wait something
that's going to be wave after wave and
we're going to learn over time what this
thing
really is
do you see the
midterm elections coming off without a
hitch do you think it'll be a nice
smooth
orderly
i don't say transition to power i don't
want to assume what direction the
elections are going to go do you think
it's going to be a nice smooth election
november
uh you're asking one of the middle
children
what to do about crazy mommy and crazy
daddy and my feeling is is that uh
you know
dad should go off uh and and uh into his
his uh meth den
and mom should should move out of the
house with her various lovers and
uh the same people who are left uh
should try to get back to the united
states of america i don't know how to do
this i i i view the republican and
democratic parties as being dead enders
uh
you know again it's the it's the thelma
and louise problem d do you decide that
uh thelma is better than louise if
louise takes longer to hit the ground
you know by a nanosecond
i don't know i i view i'm so
you know what i've become i become a
tensionist it's like you've got bloods
and crips
running your neighborhood and you don't
want to go blood or [ __ ] you just want
them to fight each other enough so that
the rest of you can go to work go to
school and
buy some groceries without being
terrorized
um
more upbeat note are we headed for
u.s involvement on the ground in
the ukraine
next question
are you excited about any
recent discoveries in physics we talked
about the w boson mass discrepancy by
the way it's not that the mass itself is
so much higher it's that the precision
is so with tension with the standard
model that not that you said that but
they're people in the chat room
wondering is it eight times too high
five sigma yeah
no it's higher but
the bounds on this thing are radically
radically tightened this isn't new data
there's old data new analysis um and
they're you know it should be taken with
some degree of of caution but but to
that end people have been speculating
about the role of fifth forces and all
sorts of things ranging from uh g minus
two discrepancy the magnetic moment um
of the muon uh et cetera et cetera there
are a lot of tensions i always say
physicists need a psychologist i think
we've got so much tension on our minds
but where do you think uh what's
exciting you if you were a young
physicist or if you knew a young
physicist who's starting out what would
you advise
her to do
what excites you
most in physics well i
a theorist i mean we should talk about
an experimentalist and a theorist and i
think we should talk about the
experimentalist first because i think
one of the things that you've done
is to emphasize that constantly uh
focusing on the lead singer you know
it's like we're always talking about
mick jagger and keith richards is
holding it down making the thing
uh awesome let's talk evenly about them
so what should a young experimentalist
do
my feeling about that is you should
figure out where there might be money
and where there might be new tools
and i would be thinking a lot about high
precision experiments i would be
thinking a lot about gravitational waves
because that's still relatively new i
would be thinking a great deal about
which of these
hints and beyond the standard model
physics
might be most promising and how would i
go about
the g minus 2 anomaly or the w anomaly
or any of the other anomalies
um what are the what are the tools and
and then you know the interstitial thing
as you were saying uh in some sense new
analysis of old data is new data
in a certain of a kind right because we
have to process the original raw data um
and so it's never it's never pristinely
coming from the universe it's itself
directly
what am i super excited about i'm super
excited about
getting back to the big questions
we traded all of our big questions for
can you quantize gravity which assumes
that gravity wants to be quantized the
way everything else wanted to be
quantized i i
i'm tired of talking about
white supremacy but quantum supremacy we
can call it
uh
quantum maximalism everything
it's sort of like dealing with bitcoin
maximalists
the people in the late with the laser
eyes are telling you quantize gravity
rather than make the quantum more
geometric because gravity has always
been geometric since einstein
what i'm super excited about in mass is
looking at the different ways that mass
can be generated
inside of the models so
let's come up with three separate ways
that you can generate mass one way is
that you could have more things to
differentiate if a
piece of a derivative gains mass by
differentiating something like a higgs
field
maybe there are multiple higgs fields
and that more mass somehow comes out of
a richer higgs sector that's sort of the
that's one of the things that might be
interesting there's a very funny result
from dimension three it's peculiar to
dimension three called topological mass
that was pioneered by roman jakiev and
others
and that says that if you have a yang
mills term so
forgive me
if you have a term that looks like this
at the top of the cup with the double
f's
um and then you add another term
that
looks a little bit more like a matter
equation and it's only got one
derivative rather than two
sort of like the dirac equation it's
called the churn simon's term
in dimension three that gives you a new
way to generate mass that's not
available elsewhere
then there's another way of generating
mass which is seemingly verboten
which is to put in a direct mass term
for something like the w particle so
rather than a soft mass term
which
gains the appearance of mass through an
interaction
i'll stop using this mug
i believe that in gu there are ways to
generate mass directly rather than
indirectly that don't violate gauge
conservation
so there are sort of three mass
mechanism
uh
channels that i'm looking at in gu
relative to the discovery of the w
particle this is something that i was
excited about before
but
i don't know i mean
what are you supposed to say if
everything is working fine
it was an embarrassment that there were
these extra terms it's there in the
draft you can see where the mass is
generated
but i don't i don't think actually i put
in the uh the yang milsian part
uh
to the draft
because of having something to do with
the higgs sector which i'm very excited
about
the
the prospect for generating mass in
novel ways
i think
uh i expect to be one of the most
exciting things to be coming out
well
on that note my friend i want to wish
everybody celebrating out there wait
wait there was a guitar question oh yeah
a guitar question so
the guitar question is uh is the guitar
hero dead
it's an interesting puzzle um
we just had this
dinner where i was invited by a guy
named pliny yeah about this picture this
guy tattooed everywhere except for maybe
the whites of his eyes you're talking
about tim henson oh yeah tim henson is
i don't even know how to describe what
kind of a wild guitarist he is but look
up polyfia goat for the most famous
thing that he did and i give the example
it's sort of like havana unanna
you know
um but imagine that you had or um like
smooth it's got this kind of a latin
rhythm and field flow but imagine that
somebody was juggling
a
faberge egg a running chainsaw and a
nuclear weapon
and
like
it was just incredibly difficult to
imagine the different things that they
had to do when they were catching each
one of these things
tim is mixing up all sorts of ingenious
i just love this guy
ingenious
ways of taking and deconstructing and
reconstructing and i want to emphasize
reconstructing
things that our brains and ears are want
to hear and are used to hearing
but
need to be made fresh anew
so i think that tim is one of the most
exciting guitarists out there but i want
to just
i want to flog a bunch of names very
quickly people who are exciting me
plini's exciting me rick beato is doing
amazing things on his channel
we are being treated to mike dawes and
tommy emmanuel uh
touring the country mike eisenger of
incubus
um
john mayer is one of the most
unbelievable pedagogues out there so
he's not only playing his heart out with
the blues with you know
the level of people like joe bonamassa
and
you know
other people in that idiom the guy named
king
kingfish
and
eric gales and
josh smith i'm just naming a bunch of
people who if you're not if you want to
get excited again about guitar
listen to these people
um
as well as get excited about the gear
uh what's going on in gear um
the folks at positive grid just sent me
a tiny amp that is
effectively your charge you know it's
a little cube this big and i've got the
world's greatest amplifiers simulated
inside of this tiny little thing
what's going on at neural dsp
in their ability to simulate and capture
instruments and then you can
you can capture like your own amplifier
and digitize it
so doug castro is doing amazing things
the people at high vibe acoustic guitar
are blowing my mind by putting reverb
echo
inside a classical instrument
effectively or a wood instrument
this is out of france
and what they're doing is turning our
they're blurring the line between an
electric and acoustic guitar so you can
have distortion on an acoustic guitar
because it takes the signal in and then
it transforms it and then it uses the
vibrating wood which is where we hear
most of the sound it's not from the
strings it's from the wood
that stuff is being vibrated by these
little uh i forgot actuators or whatever
they could call them
i think guitar is incredibly exciting
right now and i think that it what what
we're missing
is we're missing spontaneity and the
blues and whatever it is that caused
every show to be wildly different we
have too many people practicing very
very carefully
um
and i'll just shout out tosun abbasi and
misha mansour and i'm going to have more
to say about this
good
well uh eric can't thank you enough
people are asking you to break out a
guitar but i don't ask you to plan that
out so unless you happen to have a
little uh strat nearby we'll have to do
that next time and people are asking us
to go deep into the mug so i think
what we should do next time is explore
the mug in some detail so on this
channel i would love to do that
but i would like to get some video aids
and the two of us get excited
about letting people know here's the
recipe for the universe so that maybe
not everybody becomes a quantum field
theorist instantly
but this is the greatest show on earth
there's nothing more interesting than
this
and
you shouldn't get frozen out of it just
because uh you didn't math didn't agree
with you in high school so that's what i
have to say
that's right so we tied in guitar
strings and string theory
so eric we do have facilities for that
we have an enormous green screen glass
white board down here at uc san diego
where you're always welcome you know
where your office is and japanese
we have japanese whiskey we have cuban
cigars we have giant mushrooms
and we have uh assorted accoutrements to
go along with that i want to notify
people next week there's going to be a
big press release coming from the event
horizon telescope headed by my friend
shep doleman at harvard center for
astrophysics and they're making an
announcement involving a black hole in
the milky way galaxy now i don't know
about you but i have a feeling it has to
do with the ginormous six million solar
mass at the center of black hole the
black hole the black hole unless they've
discovered another black hole and that
would be almost equal you don't know
what this announcement is are you
teasing us this is a announcement of a
press conference coming on thursday next
week the 12th of may i have a video
queued up i've done an interview
i i don't know i have my very strong
suspicions and so i'll have a video out
that day
about the results on this channel so i
hope people will subscribe
i do a lot of uh introductory kind of
physics videos but i do a lot of
advanced physics and i take the
experimental attack as eric said i love
to go deep dive i love my theorist
friends and my best friends are
theorists including eric and stefan you
want your daughter to marry one that i
would i would i would allow
one of them yeah
but uh but in the same token in favor of
mixed marriages
that's right uh experimentalists need
some love too uh the unsung
exterminators of all theories in the
universe so for now and i wish you all
a uh
a fruitful cinco de mayo we're going to
go out drinking uh next time we're
together some tequila and uh and we'll
have to avoid the the anomalous worms so
i want to wish everybody that and tune
in next time to the into the impossible
podcast with your fearful host dr brian
keating and his his friendly friend uh
eric you're looking wonderful can't wait
till we're in person in all seriousness
miss you buddy
been too long
all right brother best to everybody and
i'll talk to you soon bye